billets en vente maintenant mec
attraper des
billets en vente maintenant mec billets en vente
maintenant
mec
exclusivement dans les salles de cinéma
bonjour peter je te connais nous avons commencé à
recevoir des visiteurs de tous les
univers tout cela est de ma faute
je promets que je vais arranger ça
on va  surmonter cela,
nous allons le traverser ensemble
savez-vous que peter parker qui est
spider-man oui est-ce lui non
pouvez-vous s'il vous plaît expliquer ce qui se passe
après que j'ai fermé ce sort nous avons commencé à
recevoir des visiteurs de chaque univers
multivers est réel
je  besoin de vous pour les capturer avant qu'ils ne
détruisent le tissu de la réalité je vais
avoir besoin d'aide
vous les gars prêts
attrapons des hommes multivers
spider-man votre chemin du retour quel était votre
nom encore dr otto octavius ​​sérieusement
quel est votre vrai nom
vous